[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the table of round
you would have been ingrained but this
week at the round table of dim lighting
that's it the table of round the table
of round lighting what is round I mean
we have a like lights round globular
light it is round but and it's not as
dim as it used to be yeah I is that you
want to quit when I saw that there was a
post we can't say that if you go there
was a post and somebody was like taking
pictures and like doing this different
strata of screens of how your business
has gotten increasingly less dim well it
got really dim and it was a little dim
and that was because there was something
was wrong well no it started off dim
because there was no video and we had
guests and we had this idea that like if
you create like a dark space people are
gonna share their dark secrets and I
believe that it it's it helped and so
we're welcoming yeah I mean we were down
in our basement and it was just it was
just us and somebody getting into it in
the dark
it wasn't a basement though you know it
wasn't the other studio the other studio
you're right was the it was because
there were no all the windows were
blacked out right it wasn't your right
it wasn't a basement and then when we
started doing video which comes out a
week later YouTube channel ear biscuits
if you're listening you want to start
watching and then we were like man it's
a little too dim I gotta make it
brighter because this is video yeah I
mean you kind of want to see the people
but it was still dimmer than it needed
to be because it was like man it's we've
increasingly make but maybe I'm saying
but I saw that post too and I thought
that it had a temporary really dark it
was a dark time we had a dark time that
was just because something had been
dialed in wrong but then we fixed that
and then we've slowly gotten it a little
bit bright if you add this there's like
a pulldown projector screen just beyond
this main camera here was that added
just as a reflector or was that already
there
it was added after it was added yeah we
decided that we wanted it a little bit
brighter okay yeah it reflect you to
bring Ben in here to have ideas you just
came up with this it was kind of like a
yeah I know it seems like a Ben thing so
we got it's a projector screen but
there's no projector anywhere it's jet
we're just using a projector screen as a
bounce that is good too we could project
so that is the you know that we are we
are high rolling we got a projector
screen with no projector just for the
bounce that's how high we're rolling
that's how large we're living we let's
put a projector right in between us
let's replace a wall in design with a
large projector yes why we're doing the
podcast we can be watching a movie I
want to watch the mandalorian again I
know by the time this comes out like
most all I don't know how many episodes
there are but like so I know it's a
little late but I just have to gush a
little bit I'm still trying to get you
to watch it oh I'm gonna watch it but
what about what we're gonna talk about
today oh yeah she's not the mandalorian
this week is a roundtable of dim
lighting we're talking about our book
yeah
we're taught we're gonna we're gonna go
into specific story points based on your
questions comments desires the lost
causes a bleak Creek has a lot of
details in a lot of some controversy it
appears and this is going to be full of
spoilers so might I suggest and this
will be after the break that we get into
this so if you if you end up if you
haven't read the book yet before we get
into these questions just stop this
podcast and go pick it up or I'll listen
to it on audible you listen to this
podcast and you haven't read our book
well you can listen to the audio version
of the book and it's kind of like a good
replacement for ear biscuits or you know
for a little bit so go to go to autumn
woods like it sounds like go to Amazon
get over 13 get the audible gets
together get the audible version of the
book and listen to that thing and then
come back
back and enjoy this discussion now if
you're if you're the kind of person
who's like I'm not reading the book I
don't care how many times you guys say
I'm not a reader we respect that castle
or whatever I'd still push back a little
bit on that and say just read it just if
you're gonna read one book read this
book and then if you still are like I'm
not a reader and I'm not gonna make my
first book I ever read your book then
just keep listening then just talk about
it like if you haven't read it's not
gonna be that I mean we're gonna get
into a lot of a lot of things but you
know it's not gonna ruin it for you if
ever do go back on that and decide to
read I mean it's it's I'm just I'm just
I'm gonna have a moment of gratitude
here I'm still so grateful that this
that this novel has been created that we
made it and we wrote it that it's that
it's done that it's bound and that it's
sitting on shelves
speaking of sitting on shelves mean Lily
and I'm not Lily me Christy and Lando we
went to the mall and well we were going
to that to the Galleria but really what
we were doing was we were going to
didn't iPhone because because it was
just us with landowner like we got to
eat at a special place and our maybe our
favorite restaurant is a family of Din
Tai Fung they got these dumplings good
gosh you can look through a window and
they're like they're like they're like
folding these dumplings at like a rapid
speed something that would be like one
of those satisfying manufacturing videos
that I would watch on Reddit it's just
like people working like robots they're
just amazingly fast and and they well we
were placed with the robots oh my gosh
and the dumplings are so good
dumpling robots I mean the weight was
two hours but when I finally got in
there I got what do you order from there
because I ordered the I ordered the crab
and pork dumplings I'm shorter a little
bit everything I once you eat those
everything else is I'm grabbing port
together yeah those are the best ones
soup dumplings you like bite the edge
and soup comes out and then you dip it
in
vinegar and the hot sauce these stuff I
don't think I would enjoy eating those
with you
okay well Anna listen you make noises
like that
I put yeah I'll put the first one in my
mouth can only imagine you have a system
and it you know they're not the best
things for you especially when you eat
as many as I eat so I try not to go
there but like once a quarter but when I
go well I go hard I put the first one I
put in my mouth I was like this thing is
so good I close my eyes man I'm sitting
there in the restaurant and I've been
transported to Shanghai Shanghai for you
and I'm just like savoring it and that
that's that's one of my happy places you
know when you're like going through a
surgery you like having a sister moved
or you're like I appreciate your passion
about like you need to go to a happy
place I'm guess where I'm going what's
ramen pork in my mouth
you're really easily distracted today
like you've gotten off on two tangents
oh the book yeah yeah the book that's
what we're talking so we are waiting so
we go over to Barnes & Noble and I'm
like oh I bet you bleed Creek is here
because like yeah I saw it
I've been in here a few days ago and it
sits on this shelf right there at the
front like at the table like new fiction
yeah the table that you want to be on I
felt you know I I kind of I looked at it
but I didn't want to like sit there and
like pick it up and like stare at it
like I'd like a lost child in the mall
and I think about signing it Christie
was like you should sign because then
you have to have this weird interaction
with with mr. Noble or mr. Barnes
excuse me sir why are you writing in the
books like well like you know I'm one of
the authors of this book it's like
depending on where it's where it's
printed online you might not see me as
the author you might only see Rhett
mcLaughlin because apparently it's not
enough space to put two authors on stuff
yeah but I but I am on the front of the
book and if you when you put the
discounted sticker you also put that
over my name so it's a novel for number
one New York Times bestselling
Thurs Rhett mcLaughlin and 20% off
percent off yeah I just get the short
end of the stick man or your name
shorter with the second book I want my
name needs to be first okay is that a
deal
you just said okay the two TBD we need
to figure that out so I was a little
self-conscious and then we kind of
walked away I'll say I know what the
book like looks like I'm not gonna buy
it and you know there's escalators in
there and I just noticed when I went up
the escalator that I was like I was
turning back and looking down and
looking at my book I just couldn't
believe it
we had a we have a novel in Barnes &
Noble I went to the other places to the
Romans I guess is how you pronounce that
yeah and Pasadena and which is that
that's my go to I like that is
independent bookstore and they got a lot
of cool stuff it's right next to the
lammle which incidentally subtitled
movies I saw no I saw Jojo rabbit there
oh why didn't you invite me
I just just took Sheppard just me and
Sheppard what's it rated pg-13
he's 13 he's 11 but uh I was with him I
guided him through it okay boy speaking
of tangents is it good I got a CI I mean
take away what tt was also in the
mandalorian it's uh he's a freaking jerk
so good it's so good but I'm not talking
about that I don't wanna get off on that
tangent isn't he great though I mean
he's great in that I'd like to meet him
he's even great as Hitler when someone
can make Hitler likable and boiler alert
know him that guy Meaghan II I'm not
gonna give away anything because he
doesn't really make Hitler likable if
you understand what Hitler represents in
that movie okay anyway so so I was long
I was longingly looking at the book as I
was going to do a second and third floor
but I didn't want my I didn't want
Christie to see me looking at it I
thought she was like you looking down
there's your book aren't you I mean how
often do you get to look in a bookstore
and see your own book it's pretty it's
thrilling man
well I wouldn't I was in Romans and I I
was like well of course I gotta find the
book and I was actually thinking I might
sign it because last time I was in
Romans one of the employees came up to
me and was like Brett would you mind
signing some copies of the book of
mythicality because they had that out in
the like Internet humor section area and
with all the other youtuber books but
that was more excited about this cuz I
was like our books gonna be in the
fiction section and like the part of the
book store that everybody goes not the
Internet humor that like only if you're
lost on your way to the bathroom do you
find it right let's be good for the
toilet and so it's not quite as well
organized and set up as a Barnes & Noble
in that there's also like five entrances
to this book store and you don't know
what what's the front there's multiple
cashiers and I love that because it
makes it easy to steal their books you
know they got they got to spread out
their security right yeah I'm rolling
out a tear with entry with books like
you know dooms a thick book but when you
got multiple exits you just you just you
just bide your time and you're taking
that dune down your pants that's got a
lot of junk in his trunk shape like a
book
I've not and I do not advocate stealing
books but you can put it down your pants
just pull it back out and purchase it so
I go to the fiction section and they
have new and noteworthy that's what they
call it I think and there it was
well being as I was a new does that mean
it wasn't noteworthy well no it was on
its new and no it was both not either/or
and but then they had the bestsellers
section which is like a nice shelf with
like a really nice light on it yeah we
weren't on that which I was like what
but that was before we were technically
a best-seller no this was yesterday
named get to memo so I almost well a
couple of things
I almost offered to sign one or two but
then you're only two ladies only two you
decided not and then I was almost like
well how come we put it on the
bestseller it is a best-seller
you know so you went you thought about
going into negotiations you're like oh
I'm excuse me I'd be more than happy to
sign my novel if you'd be more than
happy to put it under the lights yeah
yeah yeah so we can you knew these last
two I think it has moved him over but
that's a cool thing a lot of people have
been reporting that they've been going
to various bookstores and they're out
they've sold out of a number of these so
they're in their business more on the
way they just running already yeah and
the new printing is gonna say New York
Times best seller Baylor something like
that right that will be printed on it
it's not gonna be a sticker but it will
be over my name yeah you were taking
links they take my name off of the book
and it's gonna say York Times best it's
gonna say a novel from number one New
York Times bestselling authors Rhett
mcLaughlin and this is also a New York
Times best-selling book that's what its
gonna say yeah sorry link but you know
what you date you're in the big sentence
the mock-up but I didn't open it you're
in the picture in the back and you're
standing in front of me so I think that
makes up for it I love the fact that you
you knew that before you looked at it
like you know that I'm standing in front
of you in that picture no I well I knew
that I knew that when we chose this
picture because you didn't you're
someone I know I think you always seen a
little bit in front of me because I'm
taller but this is like your elbow is
all the way across my belly button
that's a linen that's just a little too
far in front my face is way bigger than
your face it's because like not only I
think that it's the the the wide-angle
lens that they're using to take this
picture with so typically we'd be the
same size but my head looks really
really small and really far away
so I die all evens out is what I'm
getting at I don't know if you won't
answer oh and another thing I thought is
it's a really cool cover but people are
putting like really bright colors on
covers now kind of playing like the
YouTube thumbnail game yeah with book
covers do we lose and I was like I don't
know how much I would just
it's a really cool cover but i don't
know how i catching it is when you just
put it next to like 20 other book yeah
it doesn't have the it the letter should
have been neon pink yeah so maybe the
next maybe the next printing well we
should call them right now and go all
neon with a no explanation it's all neon
this time yeah got to get those clicks
okay we're going to answer some
questions about the book this is a good
time for you to pause the podcast and go
buy the book and read it
Bleak Creek calm but before we answer
that question we're gonna tell you where
you can get this what do you call that
tie-dyed hoodie hoodie I'll call it a
hoodie look at this this is like turtle
tie-dye look at that now I got
headphones on underneath that said
that's why it looks so odd and you can
look this odd to headphones not supplied
go to mythical calm this is freshly
hitting the store upon the video release
or maybe it's not even a show tomorrow
one day yeah so if you're watching this
on day one you got a way that you got to
be ready cuz you know this thing's gonna
sell out because it's warm it's hoodie
ish and the people like the tie-dye I
can't get enough of tie-dyed things so
it sells out quick so go over there and
be a part of the reason its selling out
check it check out the back everyone's
unique it's like a snowflake because
this really tight guy that's right and
we're also selling snowflakes cuz it's
that time of year right mythical calm
all types of stuff including gift cards
I recommend asking for gift cards from
mythical dot-com for the holidays that's
a good thing to ask for people to give
you or for you to give other people if
you're not selfish my grandma used to
get me McDonald's gift cards Oh crazy
I've told you this Christie's parents
gave gave us so many McDonald's gift
cards once we moved out here that like
we had a stack of like 25 well they knew
there's a lot of McDonald's out here in
California
I gotta eat yeah I should we don't tend
to use them well okay then
sell him we buy a lot of the humble
ministry McDonald's for the show I
should you bring him in yeah
mythical calm rep you boys be your
mythical best so we have questions from
loyal listeners and avid readers a lot
and a lot of discussions happening on
the mythical society discord as well so
I think that's gonna we've read all of
that so I think that's going to color
some of our answers and I think that I
know we should wait for the Ruby
questions until the end so let's just
let's save those but start anywhere you
won't start let's start with a question
from mythical cop life okay we've met
her a number of times that's why we're
in her profile picture very engaged
member of the mythical community society
etc I would love to know more on white
woods backstory on transforming from a
seemingly normal person to the
headmaster slash cult leader he became
what made him decide to go the route of
forming a reform school was there no
other way to get his Ruby back this is a
I think that this question represents or
is related to a conversation that I have
seen quite a lot of people having right
yeah I feel like the fact that our
antagonist is revealed to have some
humanity and almost might elicit some of
your sympathy is something that people
are kind of struggled with that struggle
with sort of wrapping their minds around
what am I supposed to think about this
guy mm-hmm are you guys trying to
justify his actions by saying by giving
you know explaining that the motivation
is is him
whatever he came for his daughter and
some people are like obviously I don't
care what your motivation was your
actions have hurt so many more people
that I think aren't I'll just say first
thing our intention in doing that was
unlike what was the bag dude in Captain
Planet I never watched Captain Planet it
was the guy who polluted four and it
seemed like the reason that the guy who
polluted it was the evil dude and
Captain Planet it seems like he just got
a kick out it's polluting the earth oh
I'm getting a message
your hair is missing my lucky that you
told Mike that bothering you thank you
Jenna's bothered because my hair was
messed up after the hoodie yeah I was
gonna let it ride you weren't gonna say
thanks I couldn't tell I couldn't tell
from my angle but he was he polluted and
as a kid watching that I was just like
this guy is just evil for the sake of
being evil like I didn't even make any
connection to and I don't know if the
show did make a connection to no oh no
this guy is committed to industry and
therefore its pollution is just a
byproduct it seems like he just was a
bad dude who wanted to pollute the
planet but I think in reality everyone
who does something that is wrong for the
most part has their own internal
morality that is telling them that what
they're doing is justified right most
people make the decisions and they
rationalize them and we just kind of
wanted something that you take this
person and you've got all this hate
built up for them and then you see that
Oh
actually he has reasons that doesn't
excuse his actions but the world is a
messy place yeah but if people are
complicated it's not justification you
know but it's its explanation I mean
it's like didn't you want to know it's
like wow why is this guy doing this why
you know he's he's constructed I mean I
guess that's the question like why make
a school why I have a roof
form school and well that's because
that's what he knows he was a he was a
principal in his former life
so he's where he has run a school before
and there was an opportunity because
with the way that Bleak Creek worked
that there was a there was a need for
someone to step in and say I can solve
one of your biggest problems which is
you know I can I can make you I can
address your one of your biggest fears
which is what's going to happen to our
children are they going to stay you know
are they going to stay on the straight
and narrow or they gonna gonna go
wayward you know as a parent you they're
just times when you're struck with oh my
gosh what how are how are you how are my
children gonna turn out and am i doing
enough you know am i doing enough to to
help them become contributing members of
society like people who follow their
heart that are kind you know you want
but I mean if you oversimplify that or
if at times as a parent you just get to
like I just want him to act right like
if I could just do that then maybe
everything else and fall into place
because if they start acting wrong then
that's a red flag they're like
something's really going wrong deeper
you know that I'm really screwing up as
a parent and so I think he was smart
enough to see that like that fear goes
very deep you know in a parent so if I
can if I can tap into that and present
the solution for for a kid that they're
just like throwing their hands up I
don't know what to do with this kid you
know she's she's pulling the pants off
of mannequins yeah she's embarrassing me
she's she's you know they're they're
interrupting prayers at the at the at
the pig-picking then that's yours it's a
nice simple solution and hey the kids
don't you not to live with me anymore
well I think there's I think there's
three there's three contributing factors
right that kind of the first thing was
the keeper specifically asked for kids
who have kind of gone their own way
right kids who weren't falling in line
so you got to find those kids right
right that's his problem and so so if
you okay okay and then the second thing
is is that he's got experience with
school administration and then the third
thing is he's kind of what you're
getting at which is early 90s North
Carolina really America in general we're
still in the midst of moral panic that
really started it really kind of hit his
peak in the 80s when parents started
really worrying about Satanism I mean
I'm I remember very very clearly like
there was a whole lot of moral panic
around people actually worshiping Satan
like like we actually were told that no
you guys people are worshipping Satan
never mind the fact that the whole
Church of Satan was started as almost a
mockery of the idea of religion in
general I remember thinking I remember
thinking as a kid I was like so you're
telling me that there are people who
worship Satan which means that they
believe in the framework that there's a
God and there's a Satan and they're
choosing the bad guy like this is
illogical on so many different levels
and and I was you're buying into the
worldview that includes Satan and then
choosing him I think but I that's just
that I'm not saying that no one no one
does that but what is not a societal
problem we never was we knew enough bad
kids to be like oh that's a bad kid I'd
hate a baby I bet he would like to
worship sin well indeed he's not saying
that he does but and then we were told
that if you if you played all the all
this rock music backwards back mass ting
like we would literally go like masking
masking yeah we would literally go to
these presentations where these guys
would get up and they would play Led
Zeppelin and ac/dc and the other bands
backwards and show all the satanic
messages was power is Satan that that's
what Robert Plant saying in Reverse on a
song right yeah and I remember that
being a film from the 70s it seemed like
a seventies ish
film that was then screened again in the
early early 90s for us at at Campbell
University we were behind well it was
you know as it says they were still
trying to eradicate the Led Zeppelin was
still popular but I think this is what
I'm pointing at is in line with what you
were saying before which is what an
effective way to manipulate people and
manipulate their behavior is to
understand what their greatest fears are
and then you can basically just begin
selling them any kind of [ __ ] you
want to within especially within the if
it works within the framework of what
they already but exactly so I'm saying
is if you tell people that rock music is
actually a subversive way to worship
Satan and that's consistent with the
fears that they already have about it
then then you can get them to believe
things like people are intentionally
putting satanic messages into their song
because they legitimate ly worship Satan
if anyone actually ever did that it was
because they were playing into in a
tongue-in-cheek way but anyway so
Whitewood is in a community where this
is the way this is the way people think
and he's like this is what my experience
is and this is these are the kids that I
need in order to accomplish my mission
so you put all you do that mathematical
equation and you kind of come up with a
really strict reform school that the
kids have to live at so you got to have
control right and then of course you
ventually got to get some other adults
to help you out and you've got maybe
like them as well and the way you do
that is twofold one you you play a mean
organ at the church I mean trustworthy
it's hard to argue with that he's there
every Sunday playing that organ you know
that means a lot
he doesn't you know he might have made a
run at being a pastor but like that
takes a lot more time yeah and then the
second thing is you master that pit
barbecue and you win them over yeah you
win them over
you people can overlook a world of hurt
literally they overlooked like deaths
and which is something that we wrestled
with because it's like man once you have
kids die ok is this town really is this
time really gonna just let this school
just continue well but that happens all
the time
I mean it is in my mind is not that big
of a leap people let injustice fester
mm-hmm
especially when the person who's in
charge of it seems legitimate right and
there seems to be a legitimate
explanation ok three kids over a decade
have died in accidents at this place
it's just like and and this is largely
based on so the reform school in the
book we had we had the whole thing
sketched out but then we actually once
we had outline the entire book we found
out about this reform school yeah Lance
um I found this art in somewhere in the
Northeast that even up until within the
last decade had operated and they had
found that they were doing all kinds of
crazy disciplinary things on the kids
including rolling them up in a carpet
yep because because we had written let's
see we I'm trying to figure out if we
knew if we changed it but we don't know
yeah well we had not we had not decided
what the what the specific disciplinary
thing was but we knew we wanted to be
something where kids were isolated and
we wanted to seem kind of like the the
carpet thing so yeah we the first draft
right was it was the box and it was a
wooden box that was about two and a half
feet on each side and you basically sort
of ball a kid up and you'd put them in
this dark box that had some breathing
holes and then the guy would come in and
kind of kick it around and you would end
up upside down and you couldn't get
turned there's too small to turn around
inside and I just thought that
there's just nothing it just wasn't as
memorable or as visceral as the as the
roll so but the car so the carpet roll
is a real thing they did the kids in
these kids as a at a certain once they
reached adulthood if I remember
correctly a
out of them were troubled they had
residual effects and there was a there
was a lot of suicide yeah a lot of them
were dying and then there wasn't there
was an investigation like through
Facebook like whatever happened to a
classmate's and then like a turns out a
lot of them had committed suicide yeah I
don't remember this long-term remember
that detail but there there was a lot of
bad stuff going on at the time and
people didn't raise an eyebrow but it
caused any action yeah so it's it's sad
that these things do happen a related
question shall the velvet hook who's
changed the moniker to include scooter
leg no that's a no my appreciate that
you mentioned in you mentioned the
seven-pointed star being significant in
Christianity the seven-pointed star
represents the seven gifts of the spirit
wisdom understanding counsel might
knowledge fear and delight those aren't
the gifts of the Spirit that I know yeah
that must be this is a different list
must be NIV I don't know I'm not only
the message yeah it must be that's some
biblical translation humor for you so I
wondered if this was a metaphor for the
seven lost causes in some way absolutely
the seven pointed star is a metaphor for
the lost causes that that the cult needs
to get into the spring well and let me
pair this with this next question to
from phantomu s-- who asks can you
elaborate on the latin use by the cult
first one seems to be vita st aqua life
is water but couldn't completely figure
out the second one elect us and trot
aquam sanctum selected in holy water
yeah so all the stuff that is true about
the cult like the robes the
seven-pointed star the latin chance that
are happening just to kind of put you
put you get your mind in the right place
all of this is false fabricated by
Whitewood as a manipulative scheme to
give the appear
and trappings of a cult or some sort of
religious organization that these people
would buy into so it isn't like the
exact keeper didn't rant to keep her
didn't transfer this knowledge in this
symbology to Whitewood the key we know
you know what the keeper wants he wants
he wants seven lost causes he wants he
wants kids of a certain age with a
certain to them because there's his fuel
is associated with that right but
everything else is white woods problem
right and the seven-pointed star yes it
was chosen because the keeper told him
got to get seven kids and while the
seven-pointed star does have
significance in christianity it's all it
also like most symbols it has
significance in other places including
pagan religion and we just took it and
turned it upside down so that the the
predominant era let's say white would
turn it upside down was pointing down
towards the earth towards water also the
triangle in general and paganism is a
symbol of water because it's pointing
down it's also a symbol of feminism
because of the triangle what's that got
to do with this I'm just letting you
know I'm that wasn't a joke I'm just
letting you know now the the Latin
specifically so again my thought process
behind this was so when we were writing
this section about the cult I was like
okay well what could they chant and I
was like alright well what if there was
something that was like life is water or
water is life and then once they get
down there and they're selecting the
specific person to go into the you put
their hand into the water it'll be the
selected one or the the chosen one
enters the water the chose and I can't
remember whether or not the chosen one
refers to the person chosen and sort of
weird duck-duck-goose game or if it's
that Whitewood himself but anyway it was
very simply putting the meaning into
Google Translate in going from English
to
Lattin until we got something that oh
that kind of seems like it could be a
cool chant and so and and also I was
thinking at the time we're probably
going to get a couple of things wrong
like maybe the tents is wrong maybe this
isn't a perfect translation but let's
not pay too much attention to it because
we're trying to make it seem like this
dude who has no experience in any of
this stuff is like going to the library
and kind of coming up with these this
language that wouldn't be perfect it was
this system would not be this perfectly
cohesive system that feels like it has
some sort of supernatural force but it's
more like somebody creating something to
fool people and it's going to have some
inconsistencies in it so I chose this
and this is what you chant so everything
has significance but it's not it doesn't
have like metaphysical significance is
just he made it up to make sense in to
manipulate so kinda like you think I was
going through another religion so yeah
that so the Latin and the symbology this
the the stars the freakin stars on the
side of the book look at that this white
wood painted the spine of our novel they
did because there's the star that means
nothing that's a deception man we got it
right there on the side of it on the
spine of the book cuz it looks cool but
it means something now it means the lost
it means yeah it means or else I
shouldn't got a tattooed on my left butt
cheek oh so yeah he made all that stuff
up y'all he made it all up so then we go
back the fact it's like why would a guy
go through all this trouble and so not
to make you I mean yeah you can I think
you do feel for him but it doesn't
justify his actions I mean would you
want to do anything to save your
daughter to like to to remove your
daughter's pain and a you know to give
her a full life well hopefully not
anything hopefully not this you know but
I mean it's not just the one decision
and he's continually he communing with
his daughter who's frozen in time you
know and every time he goes down there
his heart is wrenched one more time so
it's like at a certain point he's kind
of again I'm not trying to justify this
but you psychologically it's you you can
go you can go crazy trying to trying to
care for somebody if you've reached a
total dead end and especially if it's
like this is the answer if you just do
this you know you can find yourself
becoming convinced of or just of
justifying your actions yeah I mean so
we wanted it to be a little bit messy
and complicated but ultimately you're
still I mean if I think if you if you're
normal you're still gonna conclude that
none of the stuff that he's doing is
actually justified it's just he has his
own reasons which may draw a little bit
of sympathy from you but not to the
point that you think anything any of us
justified just say I mean you got this
poor girl who doesn't want to get out of
her dress getting in there oh my lord
Wayne said it was working the water all
around it began to bubble Wayne began to
laugh unconcerned about disturbing to
anyone who might be within earshot Ruby
laughs - this is really fun she pushed
off the bottom beginning to swim Wayne
was careful not to let go of her hand
that didn't matter though as soon as she
dropped her face below the surface Ruby
was violently sucked down into the water
her hand slipped from her father's Ruby
yelled baby then he got spit out
moving along I mean this is a question
related to related quick one related to
the to the spring Joel McCrea asks are
the seven souls taken by the keeper dead
what happened to them do they go to an
afterlife or just not exist so no the
the the seven souls that are in there
are in the same situation that Rex
I mean that Leif and Alicia were in this
book so in this state of stasis which
your body is not aging these are some
things happening in your mind of course
the longer that you're there it seems
like the less you can kind of remember
and hold on to that the life that you
had before and interestingly this I
don't wanna I don't want to get into too
much of this because I don't like taking
any taking so much of the mystery any
other any of the mystery out but I will
say that the the nature of the spring
and the keeper of the spring and even
then the nature of this the void and the
people sort of being suspended in time
and kind of trapped in this place every
element of that is at least somewhat
influenced by sort of like Celtic
mythology right and that's why in the
book they break out the giant book that
talks about I can't remember the name of
the book but that's when they get some
information about the nature of the
spring and the blood and all this stuff
and the blood being the key that's
because now that that particular some of
some of the particular choices that we
made are just things that we came up
with but the general idea of like there
being this sort of being in charge of a
of a spring that represents almost a
portal to a slightly different plane of
existence
these are concepts that come up time and
time again in Celtic mythology which in
a second wool it's when we get to the
end we'll talk about what does this mean
about a potential second book and where
else could could this go but I will say
that all of that is it's not completely
fabricated we didn't just invent it out
of thin air we kind of looked and did
some research on the way people thought
about that and sort of ancient Celtic
times and use that to influence us so no
the long story short or long answer
short those people are not dead they're
still in the void you mentioned we were
talking about Whitewood you said like he
would come up with a symbology and the
Latin and stuff like if he like went to
the library I was doing research which
reminds me of this question Jade
underscore ie MRT is the man who told
Jeanine in the library basement about
the deaths at Whitewood school going to
be talked about at all he disappeared
and I have a feeling his character has a
story to be told
yeah I'm we're working on a spin-off
novel series about library dude creepy
library dude yep well first of all yeah
you ever go to the library there's
always somebody who like you can you
tell they spent a lot of time at the
library yeah so I mean maybe Whitewood
went there Janene definitely went there
for answers and this guy apparently knew
what she was looking for and had a
little information but then either he
was ghost or he just ghosted I mean he
wanted to help but do you have a
straightforward answer because I have a
roundabout answer who is this guy well
go ahead I just think that in this town
you you can't expect everyone to believe
exactly the same thing for there not to
be anybody who's more suspicious so it's
to me it it rang true that there was
there's at least somebody that you see
that you
counter in this story that's like you're
not taking this hook line and sinker
somebody's a little bit of a conspiracy
theorist yeah but every once a while
conspiracy theorists are right and then
but then not accepted kind of like you
know we look we say conspiracy theorists
with derision and I'm sure in the town
you know any any naysayer wouldn't would
be you know who knows what they'd be
saying on scratching on the side of his
car you know so it's like hey I'm gonna
help you out a little bit but I don't
want to be associated with this it's
like this the simple explanation well
now who is he how does he really know
and I would say an even simpler
excellent explanation that doesn't even
it is is very it's it's very much all
right she needs to do some kind of
research and she needs again this is one
of those things that in storytelling
it's like okay well Jeanine needs to
learn something that the audience needs
to also know in order to move this story
forward
where would you get this type of
information well you would get it at a
library what kind of town is Bleak Creek
and also what kind of story are we
trying to tell ok listen so and I think
that the library scene is actually
pretty indicative of exactly the way we
wanted to write this book so the first
thing that happens is okay something
ironically funny yeah there's a loud
librarian it's a simple simple joke that
we got a good bit of mileage out of
right right and then oh but this is also
a scary scary thing so she's gonna go
down into this basement it's gonna get a
little bit weird when she says that
she's asking about the white wood school
and what better way to introduce a
little bit of I mean she obviously
passes this guy who's kind of following
her with his eyes as she goes down and
walks through the main part of the
library to then go to the basement and
then what if all of a sudden he's just
right behind her not necessarily because
there is significance to this guy that
will be explored later but most mostly
because it's just really creepy well
it's a more now inventive way to you
know that he's being watched you know
that she's you know she's being
there's a lot there's increasing
attention on Janine's efforts and so
like how far is this gonna go you know
she and is she gonna be harmed and so
yeah yeah hopefully you're thinking that
as you're reading this that like I mean
she's got it she's lying about the
recipes and that's kind of it's not
going too great you know it's like she
kind of I really enjoy her lies and but
I was you know I'm hoping that the
readers like okay I just don't know if
that lies good enough I think she might
she might be putting a target on her
back like I said on our car at least
yeah well you know something what's this
guy gonna do well and the funny thing is
is you is you know I mean it's obvious
by the way we ended the book which
somebody pointed out in a question that
we want this story to continue yeah the
the book ends with you should relocate
rubies out and this is not quite
reconciled I mean no justice has been
done to what these adults have been
doing and what's going on in the spring
and there's still people that we love
and care about who are stuck there is
you know as Alicia gonna get back to
normal there's a lot of open questions
and that was very very intentional and I
think that one of the interesting things
that we're finding is you ask this
question about this man well I just told
you know there was no greater
significance to this guy he represents
an opportunity to make the sit the scene
scary and he's also indicative of just
the nature of the town and like link
said that there's gonna be people who
are skeptical about this school but the
cool thing about potentially writing a
second book is if we wanted there to be
significance to that guy and we wanted
to make it almost retroactive as long as
you don't do anything that is
contradictory to the way that you set it
up in the first book you have the right
to do that
well I and I did it's not that we didn't
I do think it's um it was important with
that guy that like it
I was also send the message that there
are potential allies in this town
everybody's not against these kids it's
not just in Jenin you know so I was a
little bit not wrong I'm just saying
there's a little bit but I'm just saying
that's not the process there but there's
a wind chill that went into it it's not
the process that it went into it but
yeah we we talked about the I'm sure we
haven't talked about it on the show I
didn't but it there's an openness to it
well point out making you know what in
this this leads to another question so
much the question about the Dennis
Dennis yes Ricola Julia which is jhula
483 ask was Dennis calling Jeanine who
was still in bleak Creek just a weird
coincidence was there something
supernatural happening there him calling
her all of a sudden when she was in
doubt and not sure if she should stay or
leave was almost too perfect
in a related question from Griffiths
that or in she actually replied he or
she actually replied to this question
that or I was even thinking at the time
that he might have been paid off or
encouraged by someone or some or one of
the cult members to get her to leave
town mm-hmm
I wish I had a really awesome answer to
this but the answer is no I would just
was it was just the best way to tell the
story it was dramatic timing if it was a
little too perfect well yeah yeah it
might have been a little too perfect but
sometimes you need your characters to do
something that will do the perfect thing
for your story hey think you know things
happen serendipitously in in real life
too yeah they do all the time but which
you want to you want to avoid the
cumulative effect of a lot of that
happening in the story for me like we
didn't make it there's not a whole lot
of super convenient things that happen
but there are some convenient things
that happen so you don't have to sit
through an unnecessary chapter to move
the story forward and also it's our
first novel I'm sure you don't listen
well but I'll also say that I make
I read I read like well-established
writers all the time and I see things
that I'm like whoa that that's that
right there
is so convenient that it's just you know
I mean I tend to not be very judgmental
about that kind of thing but I find some
things get too convenient sometimes I
don't think this is necessarily one of
them but I think it relates to the to
the question that we were answering
before which is kind of the way that
intentions and symbolism in fact I was I
was in a classroom the last week block
was doing this tour of this place and
there's a in the writing in the writing
classroom the English classroom there
there was a I'm gonna get this wrong but
the quote was I don't know whether the
author intended what my teacher says
they intended or if she's just making it
up but it was a very funny way to kind
of worry yeah and I think that and we're
just glad to be a part of the discussion
I don't know if I think it may have been
Hank green talking about his book but
somebody had seen something in his book
and he was like oh I'd like to take
credit for that
but no I'm glad I'm I'm glad that you
you see that that way but I think it
goes back to the process of like once
you put yourself in a certain frame of
mind and you're in a certain setting and
you're telling a certain story there are
going to be things that like even the
observation that you made about the
nature of the friendship or in the way
that they held hands around the tree the
observation that you made in yeah the
documentary which wasn't the reason we
put it in the book is because well that
was what we remembered we remembered
three people holding hands around a tree
and not being able to reach and then you
made the connection that this is like
well if two people are holding hands the
other two people can't be holding hands
and so it sort of represents the
inherent tension and a three-way
relationship
you know it's not that that's not true
it's just that that wasn't intended
people can find the meaning in that and
I think that and I think that's totally
fine to find the meaning in something
but that doesn't mean that all of that
was there it's just when you're once
you're in you're in a certain frame of
mind when you're writing and then the
person is in a certain frame of mind
when they're reading there's gonna be
connections made for me that's just a
beautiful part of the reading process is
that finding those things in attaching
meaning even in places that it could
have been subconsciously inserted by a
writer it doesn't necessarily have to be
intentional I think that was the case
there because we were very much talking
about the relational dynamics and like
leaf trying to confess his crush and
that being thwarted you know it's like
and then that's the very next thing that
we talk about and it's an easy
connection let's move to the but keeping
in the same theme this this question
from Nicole Tennant sunday rain 26 is
there any significance to the blue frog
so Ruby's blue frog left on the bed and
yes there is very specific significance
to it I don't know exactly where it
could go but the reason that it's a blue
frog is of course the blue sort of
represents the theme of water that we're
dealing with and that's why the robes
are blue and the occult but the Frog is
of course and fibia s-- which represents
the ability to go between two different
worlds two different modes of existence
a frog being able to go into water and
and then on land and and also the frog
itself is does have once you start kind
of searching like spiritual or symbology
of frog or something like that you'd be
taking it like twelve different websites
and they all kind of have a different
interpretation but I did find one
website that talked about the there's a
sort of a spiritual analogue to the
amphibious nature of a frog
being that it represents the ability to
kind of go between two planes of
existence both you know the physical
world and the spiritual world and I
think that the void does represent some
sort of metaphysical spiritual plane of
existence that isn't necessarily the
other world or underworld but it's
something different and so that is the
significance of the frog what where
we're gonna go with that we don't know
exactly but yes there's a reason that it
was a frog and that wasn't accidental
and if you remove the AR and frog you
get what father and fog is something
that lingers over what a bog water okay
Austin Reid reaper crew 96 can we talk
about the very last scene when Alicia's
going down the street and sees Ruby and
epilogue is that a hint at a second book
when Ruby got out of the springs she's
still a little kid or has she grown up
the ten years hashtag your biscuits she
has not grown up the ten years she is
she's she's the same age she was when
she went in seven years old she's seven
years old so yeah let's talk about let's
talk about that scene is it a hint at a
second book wouldn't I like to know I
hope so
yeah it was it it was it was our a
second book that doesn't exist yet it
was our it was our big hint at the fact
that we want to write a second book it's
not necessarily up to us whether or not
there will be a second book but it was
it represented our intention that there
will be but it would be cool to have
like Ruby in a second book oh yeah well
maybe we just forget about her saying
you know what that's that's just a
dangling participle let's move on to
something else listen forget about Ruby
she's not gonna be in the second book
was there it is there another question I
think
I thought there was another Ruby
question but you know yeah there is from
Lex why was Ruby the most attached to
the keeper when she was in the first kid
to drown in the spring because you know
there's Timothy who is in there is the
kid who I can't remember how many years
ago it would have been but basically
when the spring shut down was when he
drowned according to the people
according to his parents according to
the people in the town the Bleak family
that was running the resort he drowned
but we know that no he didn't drown he's
been in there so okay so why is it that
the keeper is sort of speaking through
and obviously more attached to Ruby
again
well his question was why is it Ruby so
attached to the key I guess it's the
same time she's a keeper well again I
think the answer is the most
straightforward and that is the keeper
wants more children right the keepers
made that very clear
apparently he didn't have any he didn't
have Timothy being down there wasn't
doing anything for him but Ruby because
of the way that it ended up working out
where both Ruby and Whitewood went down
at the same time now the keepers an
opportunist right so the keeper knows
that now I've got the carrot Ruby in the
spring that I and I can manipulate
Whitewood and get him to do my bidding
and so he's naturally going to be more
attached to Ruby because she is the way
that he can accomplish his purposes
unlike Timothy which apparently hasn't
worked out so well
right so what I mean less let's shift to
more of a summary of like okay so where
does this leave us I mean rest assured
we've given we've given a lot of thought
to where where we're we're we're leaving
the reader and yeah we've given a lot of
thought to where we want to take you and
and if you know follow up which you know
we're not saying that's definitely
happening
because we don't know that that's
definitely happening at this point but
we certainly hope that that will have
the opportunity to write a second book
so honestly the more buzz that continues
to be generated and around this book the
more the greater the chances that that
that we get us the opportunity to write
this second book which we're we've
already been working on so yeah we know
where we want to go in the second book
again it's just a question of will we
have the privilege to do so okay so in
summary kind of where we left we leave
off in book 1 and this is if you if you
for some reason have decided to listen
to this podcast up until this point and
now you're thinking you want to read it
do you or listen to I need to pause the
bus is not yeah because I'm gonna like
summarize where it ends so just don't
listen to this please don't listen is
there are a number people who were
inside the void been because he was
taken by the wave at the end
Josephina the girl who befriended Alicia
inside Whitewood Josephina really liked
that frog I will say that you know when
I was I was like Josefina and this is me
but like just put myself in the mind the
reason why he why keep touching that
frog it makes it like messing up Ruby's
room so much so mate that made me
uncomfortable good the fact that they
were getting too comfortable in that
room and then Whitewood snatched him up
the two kids who were thrown in during
the commotion at the end of the book so
there was the crazy moments where they
were getting Leif and Alicia out but
there were other kids being thrown in
and rejected well Patrick small and
April Lea our two kids that have they're
mentioned as missing at the end of the
at the book by the sheriff they are lost
they are in the because they are lost
cause
there are three former white wood
students who've been there for years
since their supposed deaths that's
Richard Stanley in 1982 a 16 year old
girl unnamed see that she's the one that
there's the fire and then
the richer Stanley was the one in the
oven the 16 year old girl was the one
that was smoking next to the gas leak or
supposedly I wish to but and then
there's the boy that was struck by
lightning in 1989 who's also unnamed
that really happened and then there's
Timothy bleak who's the first kid ever
be taken into the spring at least you
know in the span of our story maybe a
half maybe things happen before I don't
know he's been there since 1961 when he
drowned in quotes and that shut down the
original Bleak Creek Resort now you
might do the math on that and realize
that that's more than seven kids
that's eight kids and again or is that
no that's no so if you count Ruby that's
nine if you count Ruby that's nine so
again this again the seven kids was just
a number get the seven additional kids
given to Whitewood for again I don't try
to put too much logic behind why the
keeper needs a certain number but if
he's saying seven then his numbers his
real number was nine again and you could
get into some numerology there if you
want in the significance of seven and
the city of the significance of nine if
you want to read about that a little bit
I'm not gonna say that that isn't at
least go to the line it works out nicely
see who comes up to you well the library
guy don't forget him now the sheriff
sheriff Lawson and the rest of the cult
mary had away Shackleford etc now mary
had aways dead you wish she did say
[Laughter]
she's so likable they have explained
everything to the town by saying that
Whitewood was acting nefariously
kidnapping murdering kids they basically
say that the original kids from the 80s
are presumed dead but the most recent
for which would be been Josefina Patrick
and April or just presumed missing with
Whitewood on the lam a be being held
someplace with with Whitewood again this
this I'm just giving you this is all the
stuff that the sheriff says at the end
just so your mind will be in the right
place and the coal itself still believes
that the seven lost causes are being
purified by the one below and that they
will return as the seven Shepherd's poor
Travis they just don't know how long
it's gonna take
or maybe I mean you're mad at Travis
because he you know he double-crossed
him but it's just you know it's just to
use the parlance of the situation it's
the testimony to white woods ability to
manipulate that Travis a guy who's like
so genuine such a good-hearted guy what
in endeavor to deceive and you know keep
that from the the kids as much as he did
yeah which which then you know is there
a real is there a rereading of the scene
at the river you know that like what
what does that tell you about Travis if
you if you take another look at that
scene you know with the button I am it's
not frosting answer I'm just saying it's
just one forethought for the further for
the reread er travels one of my favorite
characters by the way relish on your
raisins
Rex leaf Alicia Alicia Alicia and horn
hat and all the other kids who were in
the school are compelled effectively
compelled to remain quiet for the fear
that the sheriff or the cult will kill
their parents do other crazy stuff and
then anybody who decides that they're
gonna say something could also be
dismissed pretty easily because you got
a bunch of traumatized kids they've been
in this weird place that of course
they're gonna say things about it and
then finally Jeanine and Donna you know
they've got their they've shown their
film which has been interpreted by the
initial audience as a precursor to Blair
Witch it well not not in a very loose
yeah basically a mockumentary a
fictional documentary
not a true expose somebody did ask a
question why did you make that decision
to do that and it's well it's because
that we don't want the loop to if all of
a sudden it was like and she makes a
film and everybody sees that they're all
crazy murderous cult members well then
the case is closed on on that we don't
want the case to be closed yeah I mean
the cult successfully you know destroyed
the most damning information and so it
you're you're you're left kind of like I
don't really I think it's the most it's
it's a pretty reasonable response I
think it's like yeah yeah okay this is a
marketing ploy you know yeah all right
so where does that leave us
well well hashtag ear biscuits first of
all if you want to continue this
discussion and if you want to join the
mythical society already remember makes
you already a member make sure you talk
about it on discord yeah because there's
something really after by chapter a
really great discussions happening
discord conversations happening and
listen we light links said yes we want
to continue telling this story the only
way that's gonna happen is if the book
continues to be a success and that
requires the book to continue to break
outside of this the community of
mythical beasts of course you guys have
been super supportive and many of you
have bought it but we need a show we
would need to demonstrate continued
interest and in fact that this thing is
bigger than just the mythical beasts so
that means buying the book for somebody
encouraging them to read it maybe they
don't maybe this isn't maybe you've
tried to introduce them to the world of
mythicality before but you sent them a
video where we were eating animal
testicles and there's that's not their
thing we do other things as we've
hopefully demonstrated with this book
that I think are maybe even more
accessible so and did you say your book
did you say leave an Amazon review I
didn't say that yes you do that that's
big up if you read the book or Goodreads
as well and so on Goodreads or Amazon
please leave a review of the lost causes
of Bleak Creek it makes a difference and
we truly appreciate it I'm gonna give a
quick wreck I was telling you about this
right beforehand so shifting gears a
little bit
I never I've never listened to Jim James
lead singer My Morning Jacket but I
started reading I stumbled upon a song
on his new album solo album called the
order of nature the song that I listened
first was called set it to song but this
is a the Louisville Orchestra and Teddy
Abrams teamed up with Jim James to like
make this song cycle it's it's
unbelievable how this how this thing
works but like let me I'll just I'll
just read a summary of this he has so
many albums and they're all so distinct
and I've just been introduced to the
world of of Jim James so I've just
scratched the surface you can come along
with me a fully orchestrated song cycle
titled the order of nature in which
James pondered the roles of hatred and
compassion in the natural world is his
latest album recorded live with the
Louisville Orchestra that's pretty
amazing it's on tour tour I kinda gotta
try to see that well he's gonna be in
Denver on May 15th let's go to Denver
Jim James alright hashtag ear biscuits
let's keep the conversation going
thanks for hanging out with us and for
enjoying the spoilers and we'll be here
for another how many episodes to two
additional episodes in 2019 and then
we're going to take another two-week
break be back on January 6 cuz your boys
your boys boys got to have a break and
yeah we'll be back bigger and better
than ever actually it'll be exactly the
same
or will it I don't think it will be
actually to watch more ear biscuits
click on the playlist on the right to
watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]